[Music]
young people watching less and less
television these days that's right they
get most of their entertainment from the
internet it's a fact so from time to
time I try to relate to some of my teen
and tween viewers by presenting this
show in a format that feels more
familiar to them so let's do that now
please enjoy my latest conan video blog
[Applause]
[Music]
Conan O'Brien here hey here's what's
going on in my world I saw the wolf of
Wall Street this weekend I was really
bummed out definitely the worst werewolf
movie I have ever seen I don't think
there was even a single wolf man
I waited through the credits that thing
sucks
speaking of wolf man here's a segment I
call scary monsters with googly eyes
scary monsters little googly eyes this
is where I take photos of monsters and I
put those googly eyes on a Wolfman right
here Freddy Krueger right here pinhead
right there scary one and my favorite
alien
of scary monsters with googly eyes scary
monsters with googly eyes this next
segment is called hard rock musicians
playing lamer instruments hard rock
musicians playing lamer instruments here
we go here's Dave Grohl playing his isla
phone
this is Metallica's James Hetfield
playing a French horn slash playing
bagpipes
hard rock musicians playing lemur
instruments hard rock musicians playing
lamer instruments this segments called
animals with emotions animals with
emotions this I was like I don't have a
drinking problem
you have a drink this monkey just saw
Criss Angel do magic it blew his mind
this guy works in our office and still
thinks those wassup commercials are
hilarious I don't know what this thing
is it just did a lot of cocaine this
otter just saw somebody she hooked up
with this weekend and she's all like hey
Brian and this bear is Brian he's all oh
boy
[Applause]
well they're mostly alright now I'm
gonna do my last segment I'm gonna have
my friend Andy rect rule is next door
help me out okay this is called
celebrities with rabies celebrities with
rabies okay Tom Cruise what's going on
hey Andy just doing shooting just done
shooting mission impossible 5 it went
great but I got bitten by a raccoon if
you find but oh hey James Judi Dench
what's up
[Applause]
Oh huh there's this is Tommy Lee Jones
what's going on here this is foolishness
oh god I've been bitten by rabbit
Academy award-winning actress
[Music]
[Applause]
you